If your appendix feels like it's screaming at all the other organs inside your stomach that's normal, right
Hi, my name is Grace Helbig, if you did not know, now you know, your life is different now. It is October
That was a sentence that almost didn't get to the end is October the end of October is Halloween Halloween is
Dress-up time for children and adults all you have to be creeps and pervs
Halloween is a great holiday to see people's true colors
People dress up as what you could only assume they either think or want the world to see them as. Lots of people are youtubers
slash want to be youtubers these days
So I thought I'd give you some inspiration. Here are five youtuber Halloween costumes that only require five
Items for each costume. Costume number one. First of all I couldn't be doing more of a Halloween costume my self. Hair and makeup fully done
Sweatpants fully loaded. I didn't my sh*t my pants, they're just on and ready to go. For the first costume
you're gonna need some sort of vintage rock t-shirt of a band you likely really do listen to. A bright red lip a
sassy
Red wig with bangs, a martini shaker and a tiny judgey hairless dog with its tongue always out and wallah you are
Mamrie Hart
That's number two: For this costume you're gonna need toy-t muscles, a toy-t sick tank top
That's likely your own merch, a toy-t 7 shaggy blond-hairdo with a toy-t bandana, a toy-t stick a** lit savage bird and yeellliingg. Ahhh whooo
And you've become Logan Paul
Costume number 3: for this costume you need a dark t-shirt
Shaggy brown hair do with some sort of dark hat, a camera at all times
And a constantly strained relationship with your friends and loved ones based on a seemingly endless
amount of fear and lies and ta-da David Dobrik.
Costume number 4:
For this one you need a crisp white polo buttoned all the way up, a long platinum Nordic looking wig, an arbitrary prop
And I'm dead behind the eyes facial expression and some sort of irreverently morbid philosophical question
Do you think animals want to kill themselves?
The way humans want to kill themselves. And look at you your Poppy. Wow
And costume number five a generic male hoodie or sweater a curly brown wig a pair
purposely distressed Ray-Bans some sort of electrically charged mode of transportation
And the seemingly disgruntled loved one who doesn't really want to be in the shot. Let's talk about gun control
tada you are Casey Neistat
Thank oh there are five youtuber Halloween costume ideas
Let me know if you guys choose any of them and I might make more of this sort of video
So let me know in the comments down below, which youtuber I should make a Halloween costume out of that sounds very Hannibal Lecter
What do you call a torturous college class? A Hannibal Lecter.
I'll see myself out. Don't forget to subscribe to this YouTube channel and click that little Bell notification
So you can get notified when I upload videos because sometimes they happen
And you don't get notified and then sometimes they don't happen, and you don't get notified so may as well get notified
I make videos Monday Wednesday and Friday in theory other than that. I don't know
I get why he's so confident
This feels great. I mean did I even need the wig
This is not that the right way to do this
It's not worth it. It's not worth